hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 12 video careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
so much Wally berry training montage
teasing all kinds of killer frost stuff
and the gorilla City episode two-parter
that's coming up so there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video be sure to
click that Bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything so I'll explain
what's going on with the gorilla City
two-parter at the end of this because
there's going to be a break there's no
new flash next week the gorilla City
episode starts in two weeks so top 10
WTF comic book Easter eggs there was so
much stuff going on in this episode and
the villain was from the comics so
number 10 the flash versus Kid Flash
foot race they totally play up kid
Flash's overconfidence it's all in good
fun he just like really excited to be
working with Barry and Barry's naturally
trying to teach him some tricks it's a
whole way of them showing you that Wally
is naturally very talented he is amazing
at straight-line speed but that is so
flash season 1 the problems that they
face the villains that they face are so
much more complex than the initial
couple of episodes that we saw way back
in season 1 now the game has been up big
time so Wally's going to have to learn
some more nuanced flash tricks and
there's all kinds of abilities they
tease this for Cisco's character to all
kinds of abilities that you couldn't
even imagine that they haven't figured
out yet the Speed Force can do crazy
things and each speedster has their own
type of abilities that they learn just
based on the way that their brain works
so no two speedsters are created alike
some of them have abilities that others
don't have
so naturally Barry gets Wally with the
phasing that was one of the hardest
things for Barry to learn but it was the
reverse flashes signature takedown move
is phasing his hand right through
someone's chest number 9 was all the
funny betting that everyone was doing
while they were racing we learned more
funny facts about earth xix betting was
banned after an incident with Vice
President Al Capone abe lincoln's on the
hundred dollar bill not Benjamin
Franklin in Cisco finds a couple more
opportunities to name-drop just
letting you know that he hasn't
forgotten about her and she's probably
coming back on the show before the end
of the season but number 8 enters the
villain so this is Clive Yorkin he's a
character
the comics the way they took him down is
a little bit different what they ended
up doing is having to just bury him
underground so that he couldn't touch
anybody else so this solution was a
little bit more sophisticated phasing
blood through him part of his storyline
was in making Julian feel guilty about
being the person to create him using the
philosopher's stone I'm responsible I
did this when I was dr. alchemy and then
later something to remember for a future
episode that's really important there's
one more metahuman husk out there
somewhere that they have to track down
he tried to do it by himself but the
whole theme of the episode was working
together meaning that things will
probably go really badly if he tries to
do that by himself so just remember that
for the future but the big thing is
Luigi's restaurant it's part of the
board of irises depth of things that
they're trying to change iris is
freaking out because not everything is
being wiped off the board so it's just a
way to show you that even though they
are able to change some things in the
future they won't be able to change
every single thing so that will come
back around at the end of the video when
I talk about some of my bigger WTF like
killer frost in dr. alchemy so just
remember that not everything is going to
be undone they'll still be some bad
things happening to people the prophecy
will still come true savatage prophecy
but it'll be a little bit different
number seven was the seals daughter just
being really awkward and funny making
joke pick between Wally and Barry who's
the better one you know who's the real
hero
don't do it it's a trap so there were a
couple times in the episode where they
made it seem like Kid Flash was getting
all the glory and people were forgetting
about how awesome berry is but then
there were some moments at the end that
took that back so they balance the
scales a little bit they just want to
show you that there are people that are
really jazzed up about Kid Flash but
they haven't forgotten about Barry Barry
is still the main attraction Kid Flash
still has a lot to learn but I was
expecting some big twist with Cecile's
daughter but it turns out that she's
just like a normal kid but they did say
that she'll be coming back in a month
meaning that's like a couple more
episodes so she'll be back before the
end of the season
number six is all the Julianne Caitlyn
CSI scenes early on the episode where
he's a total douche to her so I loved
all these scenes I think we've seen more
of Caitlin doing actual CSI biology work
which is her chosen profession she's a
biologist
we've seen her do more of that in the
last couple of episodes than in any
previous season so one of the things
they do each new season is because
they're still in STAR Labs they try to
do new sets so like the medical lab
looks very different from previous
seasons so whatever ends up happening at
the end of the season going into season
four we're still at STAR Labs they'll
have different sets but we'll still have
some of the old favorites too like
they'll still have the portal room to
earth-2 they'll probably keep the Speed
lab but there'll be some other places
inside STAR Labs that we haven't been
before
number five Barry is having trouble
training Wally he just keeps running
into the board bouncing off trying to
phase it's not working
Barry wonders what eobard thawne did to
train him and I love the crack that
Cisco made he says so he out about 15
years to plan how he was going to train
you just reminding you that that version
of Wells had to wait that long for Barry
to get his powers so that he could train
him to use his power to get himself back
to the future but they did a good job in
the episode of showing you some of
Wally's frustration like he's really
good at straight line speeds not really
great with the more nuanced skills but
he is smart enough to understand quantum
theory when they have to vibe into a
flashpoint universe so what you have
here is Barry learning to be a teacher
Jay Garrick style he needs to be an
inspiration to the people he's teaching
not just somebody who gives them
assignments to complete everybody's had
a teacher like that just give me the
homework and then you have other
teachers who are amazing because they
inspire you to be better so there's
going to be a lot more of this the rest
of this season and in all the future
seasons if we ever get more speedsters
like a lot of people want to see Bart
Barry is going to have to be able to be
the Jay Garrick to other spacers the way
that Jay Garrick helped him so number
four is vibing a flashpoint universe so
you have to keep in mind that they're
not vibing what flashpoint was there's
an infinite number of universes out
there a lot of you have asked me that
question so in the flash TV show there
are infinite universes
so they vibe one where Barry did not
undo flashpoint just to find out who the
last person collide York and is going
after so they find her and they track
her down but I just love the idea of
Cisco's teasing abilities that he
doesn't
he's saying that he has all these things
that he doesn't even know that he can do
yet so he's actually one of the most
powerful metahumans on the planet he
just doesn't know it yet he could
actually vibe the planet apart that's
how powerful he is he can cut speedsters
off from the speedforce meaning he could
turn their powers off and he has terra
Kinesis meaning he can move the earth
around telekinetically but the other
smaller one that's a little more useful
is that he can also become undetectable
two security cameras so there are all
kinds of abilities that they can roll
out in future seasons maybe because he
has the costume and the gauntlets now
we'll see another new Cisco power before
the end of the season but I almost
forgot when he vibes that other
flashpoint universe
Alex desert Julio Mendez is still alive
because remember he was the police
captain during flashpoint he was from
the original 1990s flash series he was
their version of Cisco on that TV show
so it's always fun to see him come back
I saw a bunch of you were bummed out
when they killed him off during the
episode but there's so many ways they
can bring him back he can come back
during flashbacks from alternate
universes like he did in this episode so
he can still come guest star on the TV
show but it's only fun to see those
older characters come on the modern TV
show number three is Julia talking
Caitlin down from killer frost before
she just lets iris die so the whole
thing with Caitlin here is that it's
like this really nuanced use of her
powers
you notices that was the thing in the
episode teaching Wally to use his powers
in a really nuanced way Caitlin learning
to use her powers with a lot more
control that'll be useful when they try
to find Savitt are at the end of the
season so hate 'land starts to go more
and more killer frost because iris is
getting worse and worse so she starts
speaking with her voice Julianne has to
undo safai himself in talked her down
which circling back around to the flash
prophesy about what I said earlier
Julianne feels like he's weak he wasn't
able to fight Savatage control but then
later at the end of the episode she
invites him out for drinks he tries to
tell him hey you're not weak so it seems
like they're kind of a pair now but what
might end up happening before the end of
the season is that they both end up
going bad and running off together which
is it's a funny thought I don't think
they're going anywhere but I do think
that we're going to see full-blown
killer
Frost again before the end of the season
in dr. alchemy we'll have something to
do with Savitt are coming back into the
real world so just because it seems like
they did really good in this episode
doesn't mean like they won't go off the
deep end again before the end of the
season so number two was the big train
save you have a big win for Kid Flash
phasing his blood into Clive York and
Barry phasing the Train just another
flash power that you didn't know that he
had which is actually something that
they borrowed from the new 52 comics as
a flash run except the only difference
is that he phased an airplane but the
exact same thing where he faces this
giant craft of people so there'll be all
kinds of things that they do in future
seasons like this Cisco learning new
powers the flash learning new powers Jay
Garrick is really where that comes in
Barry is really scientific but a lot of
times you just have to watch somebody
else do something so Jay Garrick Jesse
quick they'll be other speedsters that
they run into that you know just because
they think differently they thought of a
different use for the Speed Force
so they'll teach that to Barry Wally
everybody will work together because
that was the big theme of the episode
Joe had that big speech at the end where
he said we're all going to have to up
our game each of the people who had a
big win in the episode only did so
because they had help from someone else
like Wally only knew what to do because
Barry told him what to do Caitlin was
only able to help iris because Julianne
helped her so that's a really important
clue for how they're going to save iris
and defeats avatar together which I feel
like everybody knew but sometimes you
just need the characters to actually say
that to foreshadow like hey we're
actually going to have to do this
together no one person is going to be
able to save iris on their own it's
going to have to be all of us working
together and I know really ominous Joe
at the end was asking Barry about this
avatar prophecy is she the one that's
going to die Barry nods his head yes
that is not necessarily true
they can change the future but I don't
think that they're going to change
savatage prophecy someone will still die
someone will still suffer a fate worse
than death etc so more and more I'm
thinking that either Julianne or HR are
going to be the ones to die because
they're sort of the odd men out on the
team that are redeeming themselves like
Julianne is having this big arc where he
used to be this terrible person doing
terrible things force avatar now he's
turning into a good person
yank the rug right out from under you in
HR is trying to do the same thing make
his life half meaning once he achieves
that what would be the most WTF things
you do you kill them off so they are the
two people that are at the top of my
death list this season but my number one
WTF is obviously the gorilla grodd
teaser at the end of all he's so happy
that he phases in boom out pops jesse
quick my father's been captured and
taken to gorilla city just explain the
gorilla city episode it's going to be a
two-parter is just like last year when
they did the two part earth two episode
so we'll probably see some familiar
characters but it'll be all about
gorilla city so it won't start for
another two weeks so the flash is on
break next week I'll still do bonus
videos like I normally would but let me
know in the comments what are you most
excited about and what do you think the
next new Power does they're going to
demonstrate as sis code needs a new
power in Barry and Wally need new powers
too like what do you think the next
thing they're going to do is the next
video I post will be the trailer for
that gorilla City episode I'll explain a
little bit more about gorilla City in
the comics and what's going on with so
levar because they're introducing that
character then I'll post my legends of
tomorrow episode video but
congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner it's Alby please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round that started in this
video on ounce the winner when I post
that flash trailer video in the morning
so again is going to be so awesome while
you wait for that you can click here for
the iron fist trailer and you can click
here to learn what's the different
colors of flash lightning meet thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video